Тисячі людей залишили Донбас, утікаючи від війни та руйнувань.
Ті, хто лишився, змушені виживати у нових умовах.
У Красногорівці, яка постійно опиняється під обстрілом, радіють,
що мають воду та світло, хоч і погодинно.
Місцевий супермаркет - пошкоджений внаслідок обстрілів та розграбований.
Замість нього неподалік облаштували невеличку крамницю.
Галина Авраменко торгує продуктами і намагається пристосуватися до нових реалій.
Тепло, вода є, дах над головою. Коли стріляють, я можу закрити двері і у підвал спуститися.
До війни у Галини та її чоловіка було два кіоски на місцевому ринку.
Однак через бойові дії вони були зруйновані, а родина Авраменків втратила джерело доходу.
- Бачите? Це усе, що лишилося
Численні спроби припинити війну на Сході України,
яка триває вже третій рік, досі не увінчалися успіхом.
Морозна зима виснажує, однак кінця бойовим діям не видно.
Ті окопалися, ми окопалися, і тупо перестрілюємося,
просування ні туди, ні сюди. Смислу нема.
Місцева церква збирає і роздає гуманітарну допомогу. Цим опікується Любов Романенко.
Каже, парафіяни здебільшого вважають себе
українцями, проте намагаються триматися подалі від політики.
ДНР для нас не вороги, тому що ми живемо поруч,
там є родичі, тому ми усіх благословляємо, ми молимося,  і у церкві
немає ніякого настрою - ані на підтримку однієї, ані іншої сторони.
З іншого боку, на окупованій території, мешкає одна з доньок Галини.
Вона почувається покинутою українським урядом.
Мають вже нарешті вирішити це питання.
Ну, не можна ж так. Як можна один народ розділити?
Люди на Донбасі втомилися від війни.
Однак переконані: політики як у Москві, так і у Києві не зацікавлені в її завершенні.